thanks a lot thanks a lot for being here
even though we are a sponsor but you can
be safe we won't sell you anything this
is not why we are here but instead we
want to share with you a bit of our
journey share a bit of what we are doing
using using python especially in the
area of data of data science machine
learning and stuff like that so this is
what we want to be talking about today
but before we get into it of course we
want to have a short round of
introductions and these first Anna yeah
thank you to Austin so I come from a
logistics background and during my PhD I
got into data science and then started
working for the central data science
team in 2018. yeah back then I didn't
have any gray hair and now in the past
years I worked on different projects for
business different business units and
get more and more gray here so I don't
know if it's correlation or cause added
to you but yeah that's
hello everyone my name is Severin I have
a background in Material Science
I joined team the the Digital Data and
analytics team about six years ago now
and I'm the expert for time series
forecasting and personally very
passionate about bringing together data
science and software engineering
yes and finally myself toasty
so my name is tostin I have a background
in physics very long time ago and now I
have the pleasure to be managing this
great team around data and analytics as
part of an awesome management team of
this department and yeah but in my heart
I'm still a pythonista I started using
python back in 2006.
I do not remember which version it was
2.5 or 2.6 or something and I still read
at least some lines of code of python
every week even though it's sometimes
hard to do so all right so let's get
started I hope this works now
um yeah as you can see we are very
yellow we are a big yellow company I
guess many of you have used other
services before but especially if you're
Germany based maybe you are not fully
aware how globally distributed our
business is and how large it actually is
these numbers are already a bit outdated
we don't have the latest numbers at the
moment but in total we have more than
600 000 colleagues around the world we
have five business units who are doing
all kinds of logistics and this is just
a huge company definitely yes and the
topic that we want to address today is
how do you deliver data science how do
you deliver AI to a company of that
scale what do you have to do as a data
science department to be able to fulfill
this journey
and yeah you might know this aspect of
our company you might know our planes
flying around if you ever have the
chance to visit our Hub in Leipzig I can
highly recommend to do that you might
know our vans driving through the cities
or trucks or whatever you have seen
before this is the site that is usually
quite well known but what many
persons around the world do not yet know
is how much we are using data already
now
so whenever a plane
is taking off if it transports some
stuff around the world a lot of things
have been happening before already we
are applying optimizations we are
playing operations research in order to
optimize the flight networks we are
maximizing the utilization of our plans
through forecasting Saverin will be
talking about this later today and all
ways of using our assets as good as
possible
you might know the situation quite well
when one of our Courier delivers the
parcel to you usually it's quite a nice
experience both for you but also for our
couriers this is kind of the destiny of
what we are doing and long before you
received your parcel our algorithms
written in Python have already been
active in supporting this and making
this possible and Anna will be sharing
some details around that what we are
doing in that area in the digitalization
of the last Maya delivery which is our
most cost intensive block that we have
last my delivery is hell
and when you come across the German
Autobahn or anywhere else in the world
you see maybe those big distribution
centers those password centers that we
have all around the world and also here
we apply state-of-the-art algorithms for
example we are applying computer vision
in those parcel sorting systems of
course yes we scan addresses and stuff
like that this is old school but we
applying deep neural networks to
identify not just the size and the
weight of a parcel but also what is the
shape is it like crunchy is it rigid or
whatever and based on that we can do
different forms of delivery we can
Implement a lot of different use cases
and this has to be done in a kind of
edge Computing way because you are
sending it to the cloud and waiting for
the response is not fast enough to for
what we are doing there
and also in all supporting functions be
it HR Finance whatever there is also now
headquarters and around the world we are
applying Advanced algorithms machine
learning mostly written in Python to
automate all kinds of processes and
become more efficient have really high
impact on our business and deliver value
in that area
to summarize this a bit
um yes we have a large team already now
recent stock take is about 130 data
scientists around the world not all in
the central team but also in this kind
of hybrid organizational setup I could
spend hours talking about this but this
is not what we are here for today and we
have already implemented hundreds of use
cases we have a lot of them in
production there's all governance around
it blah blah not a topic for today as I
said but they are spread in a wide
variety of areas of applications
forecasting we will be talking about
this today optimization routing Network
we have a dedicated operations research
team and you can meet some of them they
are here hi Martin
and um customer analytics General
predictions Finance topics casting this
year if you want to talk to him about
that so this is definitely a definitely
a wide variety of use cases that we are
doing and I won't go into this bottom
lines that we have here but it's not
academic interest why we are doing this
it's delivering real business value we
also quantify this what we are achieving
through our projects and it's definitely
in the order of hundreds of millions of
years of value which we bring to the
company this is officially confirmed and
this is also why we are significantly
investing in that area
so this is now just as a kind of brief
introduction to know what that you know
what we are talking about today and with
this I would like to hand over to Anna
to give you some more insights of yeah
two examples of use cases that we have
implemented at which aren't production
yeah thanks to Austin for
I have now the pleasure to introduce you
to two big use cases we have been
working on for quite some time now and
that are really big and well developed
so I will share a video as a short
introduction about
nope
we didn't leave the presentation yet
is it
okay so in this video is about our last
my delivery that wasn't just touched up
on where we deliver a lot of yeah where
we deliver the passage and we also
provide the forecast when the parcel
will arrive so if you have been in touch
with it you get an information on your
phone saying oh your password will be
delivered today between 12 o'clock and 1
30 and
um yeah
so let's see how it works
Ai and data science are improving our
private and professional life not only
in the future but already today
let's take a look at Sarah
is waiting for her long-awaited delivery
that will arrive around 1pm but how does
Sarah know that short answer on track
on track is generating real business
impact by digitalizing the last mile
delivery at post and parcel Germany
leveraging AI to provide
pre-notifications and live tracking for
parcel recipients
by feeding billions of historical
delivery data into our algorithms we can
predict future deliveries
using operations research we can find
the best and most convenient route
tailored to each Courier's preference
and provide accurate estimations for the
time of delivering for millions of
parcels throughout the day
at the end of the day Sarah is happy
about her long-awaited whatever that is
and we're happy that Sarah's happy
this is just one of many examples how
data science can drive our business and
solve our challenges
do you want to start your own Journey
then get in touch with the data
analytics Center of Excellence or your
divisional data science experts
[Music]
foreign
we have been working on this topic for
quite some time and I think at the
beginning it doesn't seem like a very
complicated topic we work together in
two teams so we had an operations
research team that focused on the route
optimization and then we had the data
science team working on the delivery
time window prediction and when you look
at it you start out with your deliveries
that are spread out across the city and
the first thing you think about okay
it's it's an easy traveling salesman
problem I just optimized for the
shortest path and I'm done
but the problem here is to actually have
the time window prediction when your
password will arrive you need to be sure
that your Courier actually drives the
route that you expect and in our case
it's not that the time is really spent
on driving because the routes that they
are taking to deliver the passes are not
that long but the time is actually spent
on delivering the parcels so it's really
critical that you meet the person you
want to deliver the passage to and The
Courier with his experience or her
experience they have a lot of yeah
information that is not seen in the data
and therefore we optimize the routes to
actually be accepted by The Courier
so to be able to assign a Time window to
the route that we give the Courier
we need to ensure that we have a very
high tour loyalty
and to create these efficient routes
where you are able to deliver the
parcels in a short time we need to
ensure that we account for the
individual preferences that The Courier
has and therefore we did not only do
route optimization but combined it with
a machine learning algorithm that takes
all the historic tour information and
yeah optimizes in a way that we give our
droughts that The Courier accepts and if
the tour is accepted we have a high tour
loyalty and then we can also easily
predict when the password will be
delivered
while we were working on tour
optimization we were also working on the
delivery time winner prediction and we
really started out in a small team
analyzing the data and the nice thing is
in the big company we have a lot of data
so we relied on
all the historic historical tours and
shipment data that we had to train a
machine learning algorithm and then we
looked for local Specialties to make
sure that yeah we get all the
information
and expectable delays for example that
are in the data and we optimized for
example seasonal um
patterns to ensure that we have a very
accurate prediction and
um with this solution we are live now
it's um yeah you probably know it's from
your personal experience and we are
continuously working on it to ensure
that we still have high quality and that
everything is running and just to give
like an example so
the most of it is done in Python and
c-sharp and in the peak season like a
day in beginning of December we deliver
about 10 million passes and therefore we
need to really generate a lot of these
time window predictions and with our
hosting in the Azure Cloud we are able
to generate 2 000 delivery time winner
predictions within a second to ensure
that everything yeah is sent out at the
right time and yeah that's that's about
this use case
so and the next use case we have is
about Customs clearance so we have a lot
of cross-border shipments and when you
ship cross-border you need to give an HS
code that yeah describes what kind of
product you are shipping
and here we also have a short video to
introduce you to the topic
[Music]
Ai and data science are improving our
private and professional life not only
in the future but already today
do you know that we are moving billions
of shipments between countries every
year within the DP DHL group Crossing so
many borders can cause major impediments
in most cases a customs code is required
to identify the product for Customs
clearance the solution product
classification tool also called PCT is a
ready to implement data-driven solution
that improves Customs processes by
predicting and automating Customs code
classification for cross-border
shipments the basis of this solution is
historical shipment data which is
processed and Consolidated into one
large database that contains only unique
products with valid Customs codes a
machine learning model uses this
information to learn how to predict
Customs codes
as a result peace
automate the product classification
process in our operations and for
customer facing services in customs
operations the tool can provide multiple
recommendations for Customs codes to
accelerate Customs clearance or
determine the Customs codes
automatically and for customers the
Customs codes can be automatically
enhanced to provide transparency about
fully landed costs during the ordering
process
this is just one of many examples how
data science can drive our business and
solve our challenges
if you want to start your own Journey
then
yeah I think so
so that's also something that we have a
big need of because we have different
business units and a lot of cross-border
shipments and as I said in the video so
the basis for this machine learning
model that we are training is actually
the product description as a coil here
we use deep learning and NLP to
transform this human readable format to
an HS code and then learn on this data
for further predictions I brought a
little example of the training data so
it's really like written information on
the product and then you have the six
digit HS code I think this example is
not so common so you know don't know it
as a normal user but it is applied for
like when you do online shopping to see
how your total cost will actually end up
and if we have the option we ought to
add data for example the airport code so
we know from where to where the product
is shipped or we have shipper details
because only some shippers are only
associated with certain age s codes or
you have the skus like more information
on the product
and here also we relied on uh yeah the
available data we have a lot of uh
historical shipment data in this case as
well and we also integrated the data
from business from from different
business units to have a one big data
source and now we provide an API service
into the different operations systems of
our business units to yeah either
automate the Customs clearance process
or to really accelerate it and here also
we look for the scalability because it
is really needed and it needs to be
scalable in large uh yeah large numbers
and we have now implemented it across
different countries across different
business units and also host the whole
API in a way that it has a low latency
by being hosted in three regions in the
world
and yeah especially in our big company
it often of course that you have just
um yeah kind of these cases of
reinvention of the wheel so we as a
central team can
um yeah look for the different needs of
the business units and avoid that every
business unit is kind of developing the
same product only looking at their needs
and ensure that also stuff that we can
do in-house is not given out to external
vendors and yeah we end up with a
certain vendor login
so this is it from our big use case site
and now I would like to hand over to
Severin for very various other topics
thanks
yes thank you very much
um
I would like to talk today about time
aware forecasting right we've just heard
about some very big solutions that that
we are running but of course we are also
running a lot of yeah let's say standard
forecasting topics in yeah smaller and
bigger varieties
but what do I mean by time aware
forecasting
by the time we're forecasting I mean
projects which are either built on
multivariate time series data or data
which have some kind of time dependent
nature right so
one example the password Germany land
Hall predictions the use case we did so
line hall in this case refers to the
transportation of parcels between parcel
centers which happens every night in our
networks between all the Parlor centers
and there's a classical time series
forecasting project right but the half
an hour granularity we predict the
volume of parcels that are shipped
between any two password centers but on
the other hand with time we're
forecasting I also mean projects like
the invoice overdue predictions where we
actually do classification and try to
classify invoices which are going to be
paid laid by the customer right this is
this is very helpful in steering our
collecting process
um
such that we can collect the money from
all the customers now here
um it's in that sense it's not the time
dependent nature is described by the
kind of the customer Behavior over time
right and if you think about you're
doing classical train validation test
split as as you would do in classical
machine learning
you might if you have for example a
customer which runs out of business and
by chance a data point which reflects
this is in your already in your training
set of course it won't be very hard to
predict this kind of behavior in your
validation you tested as well right but
this is information leakage in that
sense that that we need to prevent and
therefore time we're forecasting
actually plays quite an important role
in almost any of our projects because
you you will most likely find always
some time dependence that that you need
to reflect
now to fully understand our perspective
and our solution
um just some background what we
typically do is that we train a global
regression models or classification
models
um on Custom Engineered features right
which allows us to especially also
encode business specific uh drivers and
experience right we've found that this
is really key ingredient to successful
projects that we're running because
first of all the the prediction quality
really can benefit from the input of the
business units so in terms of process
knowledge and other information
besides of course Eda phases but mostly
it's also very important in um
the integration of such models into the
business processes right we needed
essentially we need a lot of high user
acceptance that people start trusting
your models and if they are in the loop
of developing it they know what kind of
data flows in there
um there's much higher chances that that
you can succeed with this right this is
just on the side but I think that's
that's very important to rename here
now
um if you have such an overarching theme
or recurring theme in all your projects
at some point of course you ask yourself
okay what what can we do to to scale
this right what can we do to improve
things
um and then yeah what you come up with
is a forecasting Library
um and I just want to briefly take you
on the on the journey that we went
through
so um beginning middle of 2019 we kicked
off our forecasting Levy with the aim of
you know collecting common code from all
the projects
um improving code quality and increasing
the prototyping speed by reducing the
testing and implementation efforts for
each and every project right so you do
it once properly and then all the
projects can use this the aim was to
provide and end-to-end library for time
series forecasting
such that you know very experienced
people can work with it but also people
not having done time series forecasting
before can can do it and it would cover
things like
um time series cross validation which is
an important topic which will follow up
but also things like
um wavelet decomposition which then you
could use as features
um or also for outlier detection
and as as I think all time series
focusing projects of course you want to
be a second learn uh as all time series
libraries you want to be circuit learn
compatible
um at the end of 2019 we did our first
release and with the the line hall
forecast uh thing project that I just
talked about
um this was actually the first one which
was used where the time series
forecasting library was used um in
putting it in production
and pretty much since then all of our
forecasting projects um used as a
standard are our time series forecasting
Library
um
and well at the end of the hour yeah in
the course of last year
um we came to realize that
um there's things that we can further
improve on right the the landscape of
Time series forecasting libraries and
available models has really grown
and it is quite an effort if you claim
to have kind of an internal end-to-end
Library where you somehow want to
support all the good practices right and
um so what we decided to do is to
modularize our library
and break it up in smaller parts in
order to reduce dependencies and and
then essentially maintenance effort
right so for projects which can which
only focus on parts of it specifically
if you talk about time aware uh
forecasting with non-time series
forecasts
um then this is this is a very important
point
our Tech stack has developed further and
we've seen a lot of opportunities to
integrate this further into the library
um and yeah I think an overarching theme
in in any aspect of the projects we're
doing is really
um yeah production ready development
right to trying from the start on being
as close as possible to production
because this will save you a lot of
things now
um
okay now I want to Deep dive a little
bit on our library which we've now
refactored for the time series cross
validation or time aware cross
validation
um let's start with the structural
difference between
time series and or of Time series and
time we are forecasting right so first
of all we need historic data to generate
features and make predictions I think
that's
that's quite an obvious one
but um we'll get to it in a second
um second point is we want to do time
aware cross validation right I'm
motivated this in the beginning
with the invoice overdue predictions
but there is good reasons to do time
aware cross validations right might not
be necessary for your project but if you
do you're certainly on on the safe side
now for me this also means that that you
include the entire pipeline right it's
the entire pre-processing and feature
generation pipeline that you should put
um into this time where cross validation
because if you think about what do we do
in pre-processing right we often we
rescale the data we detect outliers we
impute missing values but this might
lead to very different results depending
on what point in time you actually apply
this to your data right
and specific for time series data often
the data points don't even exist yet if
once we put it in production right
because you know you want to predict
next day you have all the data from the
history so you can you can puzzle it
together just to keep this in mind
um now having is on
for historical data to make predictions
of course is kind of a
breaking requirements to classical
psychic learn pipeline right
um
now I see two approaches how to take
tackle this right so one is you could
um store the history during your with
the fit call right you just remember the
history
um the advantage is you don't need any
further provide any further history and
doing predict which might be beneficial
if you for example put this in an API
right you don't need to pass the history
along with the API call
um but on the other hand the the
drawback is that you add time depend
state to your machine learning model
right so for statistical model this is
quite natural but for machine learning
model it's not
um the second approach is that you
provide sufficient history during
predict and then basically on your
pipeline for the transform you do it on
the full history and then you filter
down to whatever portion of data you
want to actually do the predictions for
um yeah the advantage here is you don't
end up with a
time demand State
um of course the drawback is that the
transforming to predict you will
actually call
um on different data right so the
transform of the Transformers and
predictive
the estimator
um now let's let's look at how how we
realize this
now here um you see classical cycle
learn pipeline right let's assume you
put together an amazing pipeline lots of
Transformers estimator and um you now
want to
um
and let's assume we have kind of this
the split interface right which provides
this fit data and predict data method
which yeah just filters down your data
from the full data to your training data
set and your test data you fit the
pipeline on fit data and you predict on
the test data right so far so good now
what the forecasting Library offers is
this teeth pipeline
and the TS pipeline is simply a wrapper
around the second learn Pipeline and it
adds another argument to fit and predict
right you see this the split object that
we pass along
um now why do we do this
um we do this such that we can now
internally do the splitting right here
for example this is what the circuit
learned fit call will do internally
right you iterate overall Transformers
you fit
you fit them you transform the data and
then you fit the estimator the
differences here that we switch back and
forth between the full data set and the
train data set I'll come to it in a
second why this is
the case
um similar with the predict you
[Music]
basically take the entire data frame
that you got or data set that you got
you run it through all your Transformers
transform methods
and only then you filter down to the
data points you want to predict and then
you call estimator.predict now the thing
the reason is why the reason for why I
added this before is you can further
make this a little more efficient we can
add a fit predict function which only
does the loop over the Transformers once
right
now what you've seen so far is
we have defined an abstract interface
for for the split logic we inject the
split logic to the call of the transform
and the predict
methods um to be able to call them on on
different parts of the data and
essentially what we've achieved is a
generalization of the second learn
pipeline right I mean we haven't done
any Assumption of
um you know any time dependent nature of
this split interface
um but if you think about
the fit data and the transform data you
just put in the identity then you will
recover the psychic learn pipeline
Behavior right
um
now since we haven't defined any details
of split interface we can now easily
inject any
um any logic any split logic which we
for example need to to implement time
aware cross-validation
um and while we are at it we might as
well also add a couple of more features
right like we're now able to subset data
within ours within our cycle learn
pipeline which which you cannot do and
itself
yeah let's let me briefly talk about the
split interfaces that's the next thing
we need
as I mentioned before if we
look at the the implementation of the
non-time aware splits right we have the
identity methods for for all three cases
um I will leave out why we have a
special this transform data here as well
um
and with this we will recover the
standard psychic learn pipeline behavior
and then we can introduce time aware
splits and actually our library has a
generator for this time where splits
where you can you know specify all the
details
um your data frequency retraining
frequency forecasting Horizons and
you'll get an iterator for those splits
and each of them is defined by train end
date and prediction range and with this
we have we we return our data into a
multi-index
where we have a date time index and an
index indicating time series IDs and
with this we can simply filter by date
time
to cut data into our fit data and our
predict data right and this works both
for time series as well as non-time
series data
now one thing I want to mention here as
well we also have a production split
specifically for time series right
because now the this transform data
interface
adds the future data points if they
don't exist yet right so the first time
you call it it checks is are they there
if not we create them and then you will
automatically create the features for
this so you can just take your part
it'll take your pipeline you give it to
the production split and you can
immediately put it into into production
um there's a couple of more features
um that I could I can talk about
um Let Me Maybe focus on on one which is
quite important for us right I told you
about that we also want to improve our
integration with our Tech stack
so first of all there's also a
persistent version of these pipeline
right where you can persist parts of
your pipeline which is computationally
expensive
um and this will give large benefits if
you do then across validation right
because you don't need to recompute
those splits those those steps but they
will be persisted and you can simply
reviews from there
um
and
um yeah for we've also implemented the
ability that we can use kubeflow as a
backend for our parallelization
um let me quickly wrap up
um so yeah what what if what if we
achieved with our library with um
generalized the secular interface for
the pipeline and the splits with the
goals to improve maintainability and
usability
so the core functionality is roughly 700
lines of code with a really high test
coverage so it's really small you need a
package with close integration with our
Tech stack
um which allows essentially rapid
prototyping with the high code quality
and on the other hand we've improved
usability right we preserve a clear
cycle learn workflow you can use any
scikit-learn Transformers estimator out
of the box and we've really customized
it to our needs and our way of
approaching time series and time aware
forecasting
so with this I would like to hand over
back to torson and he will tell you more
about our Tech Stacks thank you very
much
I hope my microphone is working again
so we have left I think very quickly so
I have to rush a bit but it's not that
bad because we have a booth over there
and you can come over to learn more
right so um we have a hybrid
infrastructure on premise and in two
different Cloud environments and on top
of this we have data platforms we have
kubeflow as they were in already
mentioned as our dedicated environment
for data scientists that we are
deploying this in all three it
environments that we have selected we
are providing therefore a consistent
experience for data scientists on
different infrastructures just as we
need it and we also rely on a tool for
automated machine learning if you want
to know more about this what we're doing
with that and why we are having that
happy to talk to you after the talk or
at our booth afterwards right with the
lack of due to a lack of time I won't go
into more details here but it's
definitely a super interesting topic if
you want to learn more about it
absolutely yes but tools is not
everything this is something I really
want to highlight yes we are providing
two links not just for our team but for
the whole company for all data science
teams which we have in our in our
company but very important for our
aspect of scaling is also the dedicated
support that we are providing for data
science projects we have set up an ml
Ops Department ml Ops Team because this
is so crucial if you don't have proper
ml Ops you will get stuck in the
existing projects you will then have
data scientists who just maintain older
projects but don't have time to do a new
project anymore and therefore we are
investing in Heavenly we are investing
in the talents in the best practices in
the templates and all of that right and
also here our head of envelopes also
Christian I guess you can meet them at
our pools afterwards right and an active
Community is the third pillar I would
say which we are fostering we are
providing trainings here we have a in
code Club there has been a lot of
talking about Good code quality for data
science at this conference and we are
investing there a lot and this is a very
active Community where we learn from
each other and improve over time
and um with this I invite you to talk to
all of us we are a team of 40 persons
here at this conference so you can meet
all the experts that you need
um if you want to talk about those
topics and
um yeah this was just a very brief
summary of things we are doing there's
so much more we would like to talk to
you about what we are doing but we don't
have time in this talk for now because
we also want to have some questions that
we can answer for you and again as I
said we have a boost it's straight if
you leave the room on the left hand side
come and visit us
are always there but all many of our
experts are visiting by all the time
um meet us there learn about what we are
doing discuss without the use cases that
you have seen or additional ones that we
have done and by the way we are hiring
thank you for your information
thank you
thank you so much we have a lot of
questions on slido so let's try to get
in as much as we can so what are the
main challenges you're facing that are
due to your specific scale and how do
you cope with them which are purchase
tools or infrastructure
maybe this one I can answer my
experience is that the biggest
challenges are always on the human side
of things of course there are challenges
in the technology in the infrastructure
in brain scaling it but really having
the buy-in from all stakeholders having
the buy-in from the end users who will
have to adopt the solution afterwards
and have no objections around this is
the biggest challenge for scaling in my
opinion of course you have to do your
homeworks we are doing that but then
this remains always
okay next question
um what what text tag do you use for
training machine learning workloads
um well yeah so we use the the kubeflow
platform right and then we have used the
standard Tech tag right pandas we're now
experiment looking a lot of into Polar
so a lot of interesting talks um I've
just started to implement this on one of
our first
on one of my current projects
um and yeah turns out that in in many
cases
um we're we're using a light GBM for
example
um but we just mentioned the the data
reward platform right uh so it's an auto
also an automl solution uh which we use
for benchmarking or as baseline from the
projects and also
um yeah for scaling because yeah the
kind of idea is a little bit that you
know if skill data analysts can also use
this to to make forecasts right because
the key and that's also what we see in
in our work is the key in getting good
forecasters in in the pre-processing of
the data and the feature generation
great so uh a lot of people want to know
as DHL is also an international company
by the looks of it um are there any
International people in your data teams
yeah sure yeah our team is very
International actually I think if we do
a world map of our data science team we
covered every continent except for
Australia I think but um it's our
international team everything is in
English so of course we have a lot of
German native speakers but generally
it's no problem
um to like to everything in English and
also in most divisions it's it's fine if
you speak English it's a bit different
with the German side of things
but especially with the wording but yeah
great
um so there's a question here how do you
scale
and what are your deployment best
practices
yes
I mean yeah that's a huge topic right I
mean uh if we just look at the the
forecasting projects we're talking about
right we're really trying to standardize
our CID cicd workflows right that's
where we're using Cube flow for right um
scheduling by recurrent runs trying to
you know get similar structures also to
ease support for those right as horse
and mentioned we have mlops team which
at least covers technical things
um of
um support here
um but of course you need to be able to
support all the projects that that you
that you generate
um and that's I think key and then of
course we have the bigger Solutions
maybe you want to comment on those yeah
I know my most important aspect is
really standardization and observability
of the solutions and automation wherever
you can do automation if we have a small
team of like we have support clusters
like three persons who then can support
a larger number of projects if one
person always has to support one project
you can forget about skating so
standardization observability and
automation these are core aspects
independent of tools
great so is root optimization done on
the level of the individual Courier if
so how do you account for new careers
without established preferences and
retraining models
um
yes very very interesting very
interesting question
um so actually this is this is a highly
non-trivial project because first of all
um you look you look up the query but it
also has to match kind of the region
he's looking for right it doesn't look
it doesn't help if you if you're looking
for at a different District where it's
typically not delivering right so
there's there's some fallback mechanisms
um if there's a new query being
onboarded right and then we kind of also
see this that this enables to kind of
transfer Knowledge from a very
experienced driver to to a new driver
and is also the the onboarding process
right
um currently well there's a machine
learning model behind which actually
selects the best clusters
um that we that we created based on
historical tools that the query has done
and it basically votes for
um which one is the most likely to be
picked for today right
great so we only have time for one more
question is your forecasting Library
open source if not have you thought
about doing so
um yes unfortunately it's not yet open
source and um it's been it's been on the
table for quite a while and um yeah the
goal is still to to have it open source
this year and we have to okay from our
CEO to do so yeah that's true I mean
there's some some official things um
there was a question before a drawback
in such a big company
um there's a lot of a lot of rules you
sometimes have to follow and you first
have to find out that you need to follow
them
um but yeah this is this is uh something
we will make manage okay great thank you
so much
um thank you and thank you everybody for
your questions
okay we're moving on to